you guys were known for brawling
yeah right is there like how true is the
uh
like in the in the dirt movie it was
like your first show
at the oh and and there's like some kind
of just
broke out into a brawl that's a true
story i think that's that's the oil
patch in [ __ ] like
calgary or some [ __ ] some [ __ ] place
like that were just it was a full-on
like
it was one of those places where
everybody was [ __ ] like
bikers or oil riggers or something that
and they're there's four dudes looking
like [ __ ] homos
and [ __ ] makeup you know with [ __ ]
crazy hair up there playing [ __ ] live
wire and they're just like what is this
[ __ ] bag of [ __ ]
you know and and [ __ ]
yeah that [ __ ] would happen all the time
and and and vince and nicky especially
because they're right up front they
wouldn't think twice about [ __ ] you
know
diving in or vince [ __ ] clubbing
somebody with his [ __ ] mic stand or
nicki with the bass
um i'm behind the drum so it'd be a
little later when i joined
when i joined in if they went in and go
in for backup but for the most part yeah
all the time or somebody you're sitting
there [ __ ] playing and somebody just
going
and just spitting on you the whole
[ __ ] time and nikki
take about [ __ ] a minute of that and
be like you know what
[ __ ] you and then the [ __ ] show would
be over the [ __ ] just
smashing people in the [ __ ] pit yeah
i mean that must have happened a lot
like people
didn't think that you guys would fight
back too because of the way you looked
or whatever
yeah oh [ __ ] you guys are weird i loved
[ __ ] scrapping man this [ __ ] was so
fun
jack daniels and cocaine dude yeah
that'll do it
yeah dude